hi this is Dr Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason I O
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught Philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts
sometimes it's the way things are said
or how the text is structured
but the concepts themselves are not
always that complicated and that's where
I come in
to help students and lifelong Learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to YouTube many
viewers say they find them useful
what you're currently watching is part
of a new series of shorter videos each
of them focused on One Core concept from
an important philosophical text I hope
you find it useful as well
in his Dialogue on freedom of choice
Anselm of Canterbury is going to be
addressing a common situation something
that we encounter in our own experience
and you can presume that monks like
himself were also encountering quite
often as well and the question is how we
can choose something
in two contradictory ways now choosing
right is a matter of the will the will
chooses and so how can we choose
willingly and yet at the same time
unwillingly is this really possible for
us human beings I mean it seems like it
happens all the time we kind of want
something but we also kind of don't want
that but we do choose it and the student
is going to bring it up in terms of
Temptation and indeed chapter 5 where
this is being discussed is is titled
that no temptation forces one to sin
unwillingly and the student says it
seems like that's not true that we
actually are forced to sin unwillingly
he says how can the Judgment of will the
choice the arbitrium of will the
voluntas be free given that a person
with a right will somebody who hasn't
screwed up yet right somebody who
actually had has the right motivational
structure a person with right will can
be deprived of that very rightness
rectitude without willing and in Latin
this is in Vitus right so in Vitus means
uh
involuntarily without your own choice
sort of against your wishes right and
he's going to use some stronger language
going on in this in Vitus but also no
lens in Latin there is two different
words for Willing one is volans or Vela
right the velas the verb volens is the
participle and then there is NOLA and
Nolan's and that means so the first one
means to will to to choose to direct
yourself towards the other one is a no
no no I don't want that I am definitely
against that it's no longer just being
unwilling it's we dealing against you
call it anti-willing so
how can you be doing both of these at
the same time and Anselm's initial
response is no one is deprived of
rectitude except by their own will one
who acts unwillingly is said to act
against what they will and nobody's
deprived of this rectitude against their
own will so you know this is the within
the larger scope of the treaties on
freedom of choice very interested in
this question and then he goes on to
look at a few other examples
so we can have things happen to us
against our will he says that a person
can be bound tied up unwillingly because
they don't want they don't wish they
don't will to be bound and they can be
tied up unwillingly and they can be
killed unwillingly because they can will
not to be killed but
you can't will unwillingly the will is a
little bit different or willing is a
little bit different than these other
examples what's the key difference there
it's your will you're the one who
chooses it so you cannot will to will
against your own will and the Latin for
that second part is Nolan's Villa you
you can't will to uh be against or to be
willing against what it is that you're
you're willing you are willing it on
some level he says every willing person
Wills their own willing and you might
say well that sounds like a tautology
you're just saying the same thing a
couple times will will will no no Anselm
is actually saying something very
meaningful here when we choose something
when we prioritize something when we
Orient ourselves using the instrument
that is the will which is the most
really one of the most important
instruments we have according to ansum
one of the deepest part of ourselves
we are you know sort of expressing what
it is that we uh value most what it is
that we are choosing
um what it is that we are committing to
right so we can in fact will to will
every time that your will is kind of
flagging imagine that you're working out
and you're tempted to cut short your
workout and you're like no better
persevere in this
that's willing to will right you are
choosing to determine yourself
and so you know that sounds pretty good
but it also sounds like ah we're totally
responsible for everything we're on the
hook and uh we can't ever say oh
something else made me do and I did this
against my own will and so the student
brings up an interesting test case he
says
how can one be said to lie unwillingly
when he lies to avoid being killed
something he only does willingly so
we've got willingly going on in two
different ways there right
um you're you're choosing to lie you are
willing to lie but
um you're also lying unwillingly in a
certain respect he says just as he
unwillingly lies so he unwillingly Wills
to lie and he who Wills unwillingly to
lie is not willing that he Wills to lie
so there's a conflict within the will or
the motivational structure you could say
and the structure of choice
a person doesn't want to lie but they
have to lie because otherwise they're
going to be killed and you know we could
make this into all sorts of other kinds
of examples about lying they choose to
lie so as not to hurt their partner's
feelings they choose to lie so that the
earning statement will look good and
they will get a bonus at the end of the
year that will allow them to take their
family on vacation right all sorts of
cases the person doesn't want to lie but
they kind of have to don't they if they
want to have the good consequence or
they want to avoid the bad consequence
and so Anselm says all right let's look
at this case
he says perhaps he said to lie
unwillingly why
because he so Wills the truth that he
will only lie to save his life so you
know this is somebody who actually does
will the truth they value the truth and
they only lie to avoid the bad
consequence which they are being you
know avoidant towards somehow it's
trumping this will to tell the truth he
says that he tells the wills the lie for
the sake of something else for the sake
of life life is of value right
so in this case truth is being
deprioritized and life is being
prioritized as what is more valuable and
then the person lies in order to
preserve life and so in a certain sense
they are willing but they're also doing
this unwillingly as well so he says he
Wills the life for the sake of life not
for the sake of the LIE itself since he
Wills the opposite of it the truth thus
he lies both willingly and unwillingly
volins
willing and unwillingly Nolan's willing
against it right he says this is a
possible case and it has to do with this
distinction for the sake of Proctor
right what is one willing for the sake
of he says to will something for its own
sake like you know we will health for
its own sake is different from willing
something for the sake of something else
as when we will to drink absinthe absent
that at one time was not a recreational
drink for uh you know late 19th century
dandies and Romantics and then hipsters
in the 20th and 21st century it was
actually a medicinal drink and it was
super super bitter people would be like
oh I can't stand the taste of this
actually Anselm uses this example of
bitter medicines at a number of places
in his works why do you drink the bitter
medicine not because you like bitter
medicine you actually you'd prefer not
to drink it you will it for the sake of
something else that you do in fact Value
Health
so he says perhaps with respect to these
two kinds of willing you could be said
to lie both willingly and unwillingly
he's said to lie unwillingly because he
does not will the lie in the way that he
Wills the truth but that doesn't
conflict with my view that no one
unwillingly abandons rectitude of Will
and he goes into a discussion there that
we don't need to necessarily worry about
too much in in this particular
topic but it is important for the larger
treaties right so the person lies
unwillingly as he says
um because he must either be killed or
lie unwillingly that is he is not
willingly in the anguish of forced
choice right uh somebody like holds a
gun to your head and says tell a lie or
I'm going to blow your brains out you
didn't create that situation right it's
not like you typed in on you know some
sort of website I would like somebody to
come in and make me into a forced choice
where I have to either lie or you will
kill me here's my address uh I'll be
here around five o'clock P.M no no it's
nothing like that right the other person
is forcing the choice upon you and that
places you in anguish and he says
because either of these will necessarily
come about it's necessary that he either
be killed or lie it's not necessary that
he'd be killed because he can escape
death if he likes nor is it necessary
for him to lie because he could not lie
and be killed neither of these is
necessary you can choose between them
and that's why it's a forced choice and
you you didn't choose that situation so
he says that the person lies
unwillingly because they don't will it
in the same way that they they would
normally will this you know all things
being equal the person is going to will
the truth and also will their life it's
only when these are brought into
conflict that there's a forced choice
then he goes on and he says you know
there's another way that we could look
at this another reasoning uh you know
razio in Latin could be called
argumentation if you want as some people
do translate it that way and this is
frequently given to show why someone has
said to do something unwillingly
uh against their their choice right so
Nolan's in Vitus and necessarily that
they're being forced they have to do it
right but they don't want to they don't
will to at the same time and he says
what we cannot do what we do not do
because we can only do it with
difficulty you know he uses this word
difficult toss and uh difficile right so
against resistance with difficulty in
some way that requires a sacrifice on
our part when we're when we're willing
to do something that requires you know
that kind of work on our part that kind
of commitment we often say oh I'm being
forced I'm being necessitated to do what
I don't want to do so you know let's use
the example somebody holds a gun to your
head and says you're going to tell a lie
about I don't know some something that
would be very damaging to your uh
friend or family member or spouse or I'm
going to kill you right here right and
you're like well I don't want to say
this horrible thing that's not true but
I also don't want to die
um wouldn't it be better for me to like
stick around and you've got all these
like things going through your head oh
I'll miss you know their their next
birthday I won't do any good to them if
I'm dead but I could you know do
something to make up for it afterwards
right these are examples of difficulty
you have all that stuff going on in your
head and you're like I'll tell the lie
you know and then maybe they'll make you
till another lie after that because they
do indeed have the gun to your head so
he goes on and he says um
we say we cannot do these things we
necessarily turn away from and what we
can abandon only with difficulty we say
we do unwillingly and necessarily think
about an addict who has to have a
cigarette you know when they're out at
the bar with their friends having a beer
obviously in a lot of places you can't
smoke within the bar but you could go
outside right and they've got this
compulsion and they're like oh you know
I you can cannot smoke but I can't I I'm
stuck you know it's my habit I realize
that in some theoretical way I could
will to to not do this but today oh I've
had so much stress I have to do it you
know so Anselm says no no that's that's
conditions of difficulty and it's tough
to persevere and it's difficult to make
the right choice but you still have the
possibility of doing that he says in
this way one who lies lest they be
killed is said to lie against it's their
will not willingly enough necessity why
given that they cannot avoid the
falsehood without the penalty of death
so it's not that their will is
absolutely
taken from them it's that there's this
kind of if then structure if you don't
lie you're gonna die right with
necessity that's where the necessity
comes in somebody else is kind of
forcing it right and so he says that a
person who does this is still willingly
lied there's willingly lying he says he
who lies in order to save his life is
improperly
said to lie against his will why
because he wills it precisely by willing
it he wills it willingly as he says no
nisi volen's volts right so he wills it
not without willing it right so on some
level he is also responsible for it and
he goes on and he says just as when he
lies he Wills himself to lie when he
Wills to lie he Wills that very willing
Vault ipsum Vela right so it's a choice
it is a commitment it is a decision on
some level so that resolves these
difficulties I would say and gives you
an idea how we can lie or do anything
else willingly and unwillingly at the
same time